ABC News has this report representative
Jamal Bowman pleaded guilty on Thursday
after being charged with falsely pulling
the fire alarm at a congressional office
building A misdemeanor before the house
voted on a stop Gap spending Bill to
fund the government last month in a
statement Bowman said uh I'm thankful
for the quick resolution from The
District Columbia of Columbia Attorney
General's office on this issue grateful
to the capital uh police uh which agreed
I did not obstruct nor intend to
obstruct any house vote or proceedings
I'm responsible for activating a fire
alarm I'll be paying the fine issue and
look forward to these charges being
ultimately
dropped so that's that's what he's going
to get a $1,000 fine he has to write a
letter of apology to the capital police
chief Tom manger and then he he's going
to have three months of probation which
is basically nothing and then according
to Bowman himself part of the whole deal
is that after that point his record is
expunged and it's like this never
happened here he is uh explaining that
you know pay a fine 3 months from now
he'll be dismissed missed and I'll be
able to just continue to serve my
district you mean it'll be dismissed
like it'll be expunged from your record
I believe so yes that's the deal yes
yeah with capital police uh ACD the dcag
okay yeah very nice for him nice nice
deal um very very good for him he also
explained to reporters that that he was
in a rush that day and um there was
quote a lot going on and uh that's why
it all happened the way that it did
let's watch that a lot of folks want to
know why you didn't tell anybody when
you pulled it yeah I mean you remember
that day right it was like it was a lot
going on it was the vote to keep the
government open there was a motion to
adjourn so I was just in a rush man you
know trying to get down the street I was
actually running to the capital at one
point um so I was just in a hurry and
didn't get a chance to do it and you
know yeah so that was all my
bad that was all my bad my
bad he was in a rush that doesn't of
course explain any anything like you
pull the fire
alarm and someone asked you why did you
do that well there's a lot going on I
don't know there yeah there's a lot
going on now cuz you just pulled a fire
alarm the fire department showing up but
why did you do
that well um we know what his excuse was
all along his excuse was it was not
intentional he wasn't trying to set out
the fire alarm he was not trying to
obstruct the proceedings on Capitol Hill
um he did it because he was trying to
open the door and for some reason he
thought this was the way to open the
door well
along with this nice sweetheart deal we
we also now finally have the full video
of Bowman pulling the firearm keep in
mind that video was not released
initially instead we got a a
screenshot of him pulling the fire alarm
we didn't get the full video because
they didn't want to show us the video
Until the deal was made and once you see
the video you see why that's the case so
let's put that video
up here's here's Bowman uh walking up to
the
y you see him grab both signs pull the
alarm and walk off
okay so you can clearly see Bowman
walking up to the doors making no
attempt to open
them pulling down the
signs pulling the fire alarm and then
walking briskly away remember that his
asinine excuse was that he was trying to
open the door his excuse was that he'
never in his life ever encountered an
emergency exit before he didn't know how
it worked so he pulled the fire alarm
because he thought that uh that it would
make the door open and and then he went
and hit the smoke detectors CU he
thought it would make gumdrops fall from
the ceiling or something he has no idea
how anything Works uh but that's what
we're supposed to believe except that
you know first of all that was never
even close to to believable to begin
with it was obviously a nonsense claim
from the start anybody who pretended to
believe it should be embarrassed anyone
who actually did believe it should be I
don't know lobotomized and deported to
Jupiter but either way we now have the
video which which 100% absolutely
conclusively
proves that he lied about this incident
okay he never tried to open the door he
took down the signs so why is that part
of the if you're trying to open the door
why would taking down the signs be a
part of that uh process and then he most
importantly he pulled the fire alarm
lever and walked away he didn't even
turn around to see if it open allegedly
he did that to open the door but he
never he never turned around to see if
the door opened
people always say happy dog happy life
well if that's really the case you need
to be giving your dog rough greens
naturopathic Dr Dennis black the founder
of rough greens is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America
before I started feeding my dog rough
greens I had no idea that dog food is
dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dog's food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breaths booths energy
levels and so much more we are we eat
and that goes for dogs too naturopathic
Dennis black is so confident Ru greens
will improve your dog's health he's
offering my listeners a free jump start
trial bag so your dog can try it get a
free jump start trial bag delivered
straight through your door in just a few
business days go to Ru greens.com mat or
call 844 ru700 that's rfffg greens.com
mat or call 844 ru700 to
so this was an intentional act 100%
absolutely I mean there's no way around
it you can see it in the video there's
like no other it's it's really it's
100% and why did he do it well there's
no other reason that he would have done
it other than to delay the
vote he was trying to obstruct the
proceedings on Capitol
Hill um now how could he have been so
unbelievably stupid as to think that he
could do this and nobody would find out
was he not aware that that they have
security cameras in those
buildings who knows like there is no
scenario here that doesn't end with
Jamal Bowman having the IQ of a hermit
crab that so so we know that's the case
no matter what but um that was always
guaranteed but he's also a
liar we could see and uh he should have
been charged with a felony and he should
be
expelled and you know what
even though he's a this is the the
worst part about
it he's a
but in the end he was basically
right because he figured that he could
do this and face no
Consequence the only thing he was wrong
about is that I I think he figured that
they would not that even if they had
security camera footage they wouldn't
release it because he's a Democrat and
so they wouldn't want to embarrass him
so he was wrong about that but
everything else he was right he figured
there'd be no consequ quence uh beyond
that there's be no legal consequence and
in effect there isn't he's got to pay
$1,000 fine that's
it and um after three months it'll be
like this never
happened because we live in a two-tier
justice system and it is a two-tier
justice system that he benefits from and
he is fully aware of that if You' like
to see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there God's SP